my name isn't devil so I was introduced
I'm from Argentina we have a small
training company we focus on data
science for like high value you know we
do like three-month course to ramp up
people that's been working for with I
don't know Excel or table for years so
we introduce them into the data science
world with Python and lately we are
releasing a product and I'll show you
it's like a like a managed notebook
Jupiter love environment with a few more
additions is specially tailored for
education we actually knitted it nothing
suit our needs like Google Cola or a
Chanel books they're really good but uh
we needed something better about this
talk I usually think so this is what
happens we have a high profile company
that says we want to ramp up someone
into the data science world and I bring
my curriculum and there is a an entire
class that is about data function of
programming and they're like no dude I
want something practical I want
something that some like that's that's
useless writes nobody it's gonna I can't
feed my family with data with functional
programming sorry and the truth is that
we are fairly it's like we are fairly
nerds and this in this regard we think
that it's extremely important for every
data science to have a good
understanding of functional programming
and that the cost benefit of it it's
impressive because just takes a couple
of hours today it's gonna take 30
minutes and usually people get a good
sense of what it takes and what are the
advantages of understanding how to work
with functional programming because of
the reasons you're gonna see in a couple
of minutes this talk is going to so we
have 30 minutes right at the end we have
a couple of minutes for questions I will
actually try to take questions during
the talk so you guys are welcome to
interrupt me please do it alright so if
there is something that it's not clear
or something you want to comment again
we do teaching for lip for our lives so
it's fairly good to have you
interrupting us and what we're gonna do
in the end is a quick quiz with a couple
of prizes I brought alfajores from
Argentina I don't know if you know what
it is so I have six of them they're
fairly good alcohols from Argentina so
we'll be doing a quick poll based on the
quizzes and your answers so that's going
to cut up to super to how it supports
the work so interrupt me during the talk
if you have questions so why is data
sensing important for data science
function programming for data science
because what I've found during all these
years working with it is that functional
programming applies to something like
something so it small us I don't know
counting words in a text file to an
entire data pipeline in a massive
company the process of managing data
mapping it producing it filtering is
present everywhere ok so you're gonna
apply the same and the same concepts the
same primitives to again your tiny tiny
tiny code for a script that will I don't
know you're trying something your home
and it's gonna open a door the same code
that's gonna be applied in your machine
learning pipeline for example so
everything is going to work under the
same foundation so we think that
functional programming is for us in our
discipline as developers it's the theory
of everything I don't know if you guys
are familiar with it I'm not a physicist
but it's usually understood that there's
like this this means match between the
tiny tiny tiny world and a large world
in physics well it doesn't happen in in
programming we have functional
programming that applies in the same way
to something extremely large thousands
of computers working at the same time
and something as small as your 200 light
script to do something tiny so we will
try to define what a functional
programming actually we need a little
bit of history first it was inspired by
lambda calculus it started a long time
ago how long a long time ago and the
idea was to apply these calculus lambda
calculus into the competing world
without I mean
with with the same knowledge or the same
concepts that we had in the most
declarative and expressive mathematics
world of lambda calculus the first
programming language was created by this
guy it was designed by John McCarthy it
the first programming language the first
functional programming only which was
Lisp
there are a few others but usually
understood the first one was list the
truth is that this person designed the
programming language he didn't actually
coded it pretty much the same thing it
happens with Python Python is actually a
specification it's the dogs it's a it's
a PDF then you have something like C
Python that brings these ideas to life
of course the video is both developer at
C Python and also the designer but for
example right now peter has a clean
house step aside in the development of C
Python and it's just he's just over
saying their pet process so the same
thing happened here there was someone
there was designing the functional
programming language and then it was
implemented by other people with
different implementations under primary
usage was in the sixties in artificial
intelligence right that's the their idea
they wanted to bring artificial
intelligence to live in the 60s and they
thought about these programming language
this person people that had some
training computer science minor for his
John Backus we have the grammar and all
that he also had a functional
programming languages was called FP and
had this phrase in his presentation or
dissertation I don't know if it was a
dissertation or or the presentation of
the language and as you might see is is
this idea of combining different
functions right and it has a really not
illogical like route with it again it's
creating an algebra of programs and I
don't want it to be extremely math big
it isn't but it will bring home these
ideas if you for those of you familiar
with these concepts
there was actually this completely
useful list for this talk but it's
pretty fun there was a machine built
exclusively with Lisp right it was just
a functional programming machine with
all the primitives built with Lisp and
it was a there were many many innovative
things like garbage collection or local
local area networks and I think the
first computer mouse was built in one
updates so it was pretty interesting so
about the definition it's fairly
difficult to define from that functional
programming if you guys get pen
different books about phone chat
programming you will get ten different
definitions based on what they think
what everybody thinks so it's really
hard to come to a really like specific
and strict definition so we were gonna
just give it a try really high level and
we're gonna say the functional
programming is that style of programming
right that will favor declarative
programming over imperative programming
and of course we're gonna talk about
that in a second
until now make usage of immutability
right no side effects different things
but related and also function
composition I want to talk about higher
order functions in a second so if we
break down this definition we're gonna
start saying that functional programming
for us at least or for me right it's a
programming style it's not that you're
like a you're a functional programmer
oh or this code is practice perfectly
functional or purely functional as might
happen for example if you use something
like Haskell but that's not our scope we
are allowed to break the rules sometimes
that's fine sometimes you need like
pragmatism and we're gonna make use of
it so it's a style of programming it's
kind of a mindset it's it's a way to
review code right when you're reviewing
code trying to find side effects might
be breaking your code mutability that
might be breaking this functional style
one of the most important concepts we
have is both emit ability and no side
effects as we saw before the first one
immutability and again they're related
but kind of different immutability means
or is specially related to the usage or
in data when you have data and you're
mutating it or when you're
changing it our objective in functional
program is not to change veda and you've
seen this a lot hopefully and usually it
is actually presented as a second Eva a
two pathway to solve a problem it's like
sometimes you have to make the decision
if you want to make something mutable or
immutable the solution is going to work
in the same way so here for example I
have something really simple it's just I
need to add a new element to a list I
can provide a middle solution or an
immutable solution in there one and left
the mutable one I am changing the list l
it has one new element now in the other
one have created a new one so the first
list L isn't is just clean has never
been changed a few benefits from this is
that you kind of always know how your
code is performing and what what you the
data behind your code is representing
and this is extremely important if you
stop the code at this given point you
can just understand and replicate what's
going on with your data if there are
things changing it in between you're not
social and so of course testable it's
really important for concurrency and
also the BRABUS nest of organa gained
right whenever we apply these concepts
for the purposes of a large system
specially python has a lot of immutable
concepts you might know a few more I
have here a string string for example in
in Python is immutable
I can try changing it sometimes I have
the illusion of changing it but
internally that strength was creative
right it's never changed naturally has
many benefits I don't know if you guys
have ever heard about the strings
internals or internalizations or stuff
like that where there's actually one
copy throughout the entire system of the
string hello and it's reused everywhere
because it can never be changed so
that's a significant gain in speed and
performance because of these simple
decision it was a decision when Geetha
the creator of Python started with it
say like should we do strings mutable or
immutable when they say mutable we gain
all these
benefits so there are plenty I don't
know
another example immutable things in
Python couples no remaining one of them
of course the most important one is a
couple frozen said we have different
examples and it's gonna resign now in a
couple of seconds
pandas numpy all these libraries favor
MIT ability as much as possible you've
seen this in place right parameter
everywhere if you try to do any
operations in pen it's gonna return your
thing it will not mutate it it will not
change it by default and actually they
can employ very advanced ways of sharing
data between copies to minimize the
performance hit and still give you this
sense of security by not changing the
data the same thing with numpy actually
in our class when we start the data
science part we have like an entire
class about numpy the benefits of memory
and performance with non-final that and
we have like a two hour class and when
we finish we say well an empire array is
pretty much the same thing as a list can
you guys tell me how to obtain an
element or an array it's like they say
you're cheating on us we never saw it
how can you do it and it's actually
really hard if you guys try appending a
new element to an array ok modifying the
original array it's extremely difficult
right it's there is no simple way of
doing it with numpy because it has big
performance implications known pi tries
to allocate that continues continues
continues I don't know how to say
continues alright yeah yeah thank you
continues plays in memory what it should
put all the numbers in it right so when
it performs operations all the memory is
moved in the same kind of chunk rights
allocated and moved back and forth
registers CPU registers and memory and
everything is more performance faster
sorry if you divide your array in
multiple pieces things are not so fast
so whenever you create and write in
numpy it's sealed there's actually a way
to literally seal and it cannot be
changed in any way it set flat equals
write equals false with the
really good if this thing was actually
way of like a global default you could
say I don't want anything mutable there
is there isn't but that's how what we
have another similar concept is side
effects side effects is pretty much the
concept of mobility but not related to
data programming managing systems
I've been coding for a long time it's
just about computing and data that's it
data is for immutability for computing
for algorithms we have the concept of
side effects and it's what we should try
to avoid a side effect is anytime you're
accessing an i/o resource for example
you're trying to read or write to a file
to the network to any input or output
device that it's out of your memory
still the same thing as for example
raising exceptions or changing object
states sometimes you're not aware you're
changing the object the state of an
object or others in global state which
is of course fairly bad this is an
example I don't know if you guys can say
clearly because there is a little light
on the side but up this side if the
usage of side effect is also kind of a
decision and not so much as this
incision like at this point I'm gonna
decide to introduce the side effects
more about someone that is not so
familiar with programming and they find
the quickest solution possible and then
they realize that there was a no side
effect solution or a not Mirabal
solution in this case we have a function
that it's doing something I put computer
earnings like anything can can be placed
in there but you're basically doing
something some operation and you're
adding a bunch of side effects things
with it right so for example you are
accessing a global variable that it's
the connection to the database you are
asking for an input inside a function or
they are printing in the function you're
writing the result so you're reading the
results inside that function that it's
supposed to only do that thing for what
it was created right so this is a clear
really clear obvious example of
side-effects and you that's those are
the things you guys should be looking
for right these
these things about this is not the scope
of my function I am doing something else
that it's not of the scope of this
function a solution right it's simple
it's usually trying to keep all the ayah
all the the things that are related to
side effect to some other different
plates like usually we say that the
system is like like an onion right weird
with the outer layer being the one
interacting with the file system with
the network doing i/o and everything
internal should never be aware of that
so we usually say it if you can use the
same code in your laptop in your phone
in a Raspberry Pi it should work in the
same way you should you shouldn't be
changing the interface that it's
accessing the advantages of these ones
is of course that obvious
usually right here if this function
fails in production what's the problem
what failed did it fail that maybe the
user input is the wrong year or the
database broke the database connection
broke or it was inconsistent what was
the problem right if you have something
that it's like these you can always test
it differently like separately you can
have absolute login for that it's like
you can have a more design oriented con
contract design oriented software what
you say this day but from what I'm
receiving you can log it this is what
happened this is the output is
everything fine if the input was what
you knew it was and the output wasn't
your function is the one with the
problem maybe when you read the logs you
see that the input was different and
maybe the problem is in the database but
your function is not responsible you can
go look to some other place and again
you can reuse it in every other
situation a really important concept of
side-effects is that it introduces
complexity which is those of you a
little bit more familiar with the
software development process and
engineering you will know that
complexity is this war we all fear like
complexities the worst thing can happen
to us to assistant picture this is a
pretty simple these can be either a big
ETL process a big big data pipeline
process or it can be just my code right
it can be functions
calling themselves or complete like jobs
being invoked by different ETL processes
doesn't matter but what happens if each
one of these could have a side effect
like these I don't know green bubble
could modify a variable in the red
bubble its complexity we don't know
what's going on if we stop the system
right here
anything can happen we don't know when
something is being changed that's why
again usually we try to keep like side
effects to the ends and everything in
between should be a little bit more pure
which is the what we're gonna talk in a
second there's actually a list of really
bad bad software bugs and one of them
was the Fiat 25 a machine that killed
people with a side effect that was a
shoe right there was a variable was
modifying state I was creating a race
condition without people knowing about
it it was impossible to test because it
depended on the user input and it was of
course a really bad execution I hope
nobody ever gets to this but again it's
proved there's actually a paper link
right here there's a paper a really good
explanation of why side effects might
contribute to complexity so how can we
get rid of these side effects by the
usage of pure function this is also a
highly functional programming concept
pure functions and they're basically
functions that they don't have side
effects period and that buy any input
right by the semi but it's always gonna
produce the same output doesn't depend
on the day doesn't depend on the
platform it's just a pure function like
a mathematical function two plus two is
equals to four everywhere all the time
right and it's not a function but the
addition of two plus two the same inputs
gonna always give you the same result
the good thing about have pure functions
as simple as they are right again sorry
to introduce them to even waste a minute
introducing them is that they're gonna
have a ton of benefits right benefits as
simple as being testable again or more
than like being able we can attach them
or we can build parallel versions of
these phone
testing them we know it we can compose
them right so in this case we could even
if we know if we have specific tests for
R we know it works we can derive other
functions out of it and they will work
right yeah 10 minutes seriously yeah oh
man okay
I had a ton of important things series
10 minutes until questions yeah oh so we
have 20 minutes elapsed okay okay so
really quickly reference the referential
transparency you can guys you can look
that up later it's not that important
basically replacing the execution of a
function with its file it should be the
same thing it's related to pure
functions the definition they had
something really important that was
function composition I will leave it up
for later these lights are posted you
guys can see them basically a high order
function is a function that is when
you're passing a function as a parameter
or you are for example returning a
function from another function so that's
something that it's possible because
python treats functions as first-class
objects this is a really important
concept in Python for Python a function
is just another objects like an integer
can you assign an integer to a variable
yes you can do the same thing with the
function can you store an integer in a
list the same thing can happen with
function just a plain old object Python
doesn't differentiate it in any way so
yeah we can we have a couple of examples
there of that so going back again to the
definition we have pretty much the most
important concept that is declarative
programming favoring declarative
programming the best way to understand
the clarity program is by understanding
imperative programming that it's pretty
much the other end and it's when you are
exploit when you're giving the computer
the precise instructions of what it
should do okay so for example we have
two robots that are going to cook for us
one of them is the imperative robot the
one is a declarative one the protein one
we should give to it each one of the
instructions step by step interim part
programming was thought to code machines
it was a practical solution that we had
back in the 50s and 60s when we had to
say take these piece of data move it to
this register add it to this other one
which we had to manipulate all the
instructions one by one these has many
problems you of course know about it
we're gonna go again to it what happens
if for example I interrupt the the the
code I you don't see what's crossed
right and I ask you do you know what I'm
doing right here if you're writing an
algorithm that it's not four lines of a
robot cooking it's a real function in
your company that has 200 lines and you
are running it and someone interrupts
you and say hey we don't have more
coffee you say I was in the middle of
reading and now I have to go back and
understand everything again it's because
you're following the steps one by one in
your mind the imperative feels like
micromanagement like you're telling the
computer what to do or how to do it
actually how to do how to follow the
process you wanna achieve declarative is
the other end it's usually you tell the
computer what you want to achieve right
it's like I want you to build this thing
for me and in this case it's gonna look
something like that
for example computer computing the
matrix with a vector product matrix
vector product with the code with a this
is an imperative solution just giving
the steps right one by one explaining
the function how it should execute each
one of the steps to achieve the result
and this is gonna be of course the
declarative solution I want the product
between these matrix and this vector
right
[Music]
it feels like cheating of course it's
like with the declarative ones like
there is no magic function for
everything it should be amazing to
happen and actually this is this kind of
the the key as programmers understanding
the level of abstractions we have it's
like can I ask the my computer I can I
can ask my computer to do a simple
matrix vector product can ask my
computer I want a clone of Amazon build
with Django it's gonna do it no of
course not that's too high of an
abstraction so I can the key here is
again balancing the level between
something that it's too high level and
something that is too low level that's
usually you try to stay as high as
possible with your levels of abstraction
the three most important abstractions in
functional programming you're gonna see
everywhere our map filter and produces
these are pretty unknown not is a
function is gonna take both a collection
and a transformation function that's
gonna apply this transformation to each
one of the elements producing a new one
it's transforming each one of the
elements one by one right transforming
each one of them if this looks familiar
by the way this is the the functional
the regular map function is done the
library in Python this is how you call
it function plus collection if these
looks familiar it's because it's just a
regular list comprehension in Python
right so a list comprehension - it's
just the application of map and it's
also built in into numpy and pandas it's
a regular vectorized operation you have
a collection you just express what
you're gonna do I don't know multiply
these number with these thing and and -
subtract odd you're just passing by
you're declaring what you want to
achieve you don't care how it's gonna be
done behind the scenes filtered it's all
very important like low-level core
function in functional programming it's
the standard library version is that
it's just it receives as usual a
function in the collection the
well-known version of it is also alice
comprehension with the predicate part or
the if part at the end and also you
folks have probably seen it - with numpy
or pandas when you are doing a boolean
array or a mask we are saying I want to
get from your expressing what you wanna
get I want to get from this array
everything there is greater than -
period I don't care how you do it may be
behind the scenes num num PI is
paralyzing it or it's I don't know doing
some crazy matrix mask in it I don't
care how it's doing it I'm expressing
what I want to achieve and finally reuse
that it's just also called fold it's
combining things
final comment here is that it's no
longer part of the standard library
there is actually there's in the slides
there are notes with some quotes there
is actually a pose of kiddo saying that
it was too complicated so they removed
it and now it's part of the phone told
Mario and if maybe already used and all
these core languages components of
functional programming sound familiar
it's because again we use them for tiny
tiny tiny code doing something really
tiny for our own script but for large
systems it's the same thing MapReduce
filter it's always pretty much the same
thing this is for example the
illustration of a map or a Hadoop job to
count words the hello world of Hadoop is
counting words so this concept applies
for again multiple machines or it also
applies for just one machine working
again in the same way how much time you
have
fold it okay
you made me care before so what are the
difference between map filter and those
comprehensions we're gonna we will not
have a lot of time to talk about this is
that right now in Python 3 map for
example is gonna return an iterator it
doesn't actually return the objects as
soon as you get them so I have right
here an example or is it let me see if I
can
so this is I don't know if you can say
it in the back this is what a mop is
gonna return and what it actually
returns is this iterator object that you
you are the one supposed to pull the
objects for or the results from it it's
not just gonna compute them at the
moment you asked for it that's because
it's a lazy evaluation rights trying to
evaluate it whenever it's not it's
necessary not as soon as you evoke it
because again maybe you don't need to
use them right now maybe you just need
it first two elements not all of them so
this concept of laziness is extremely
important in functional programming and
it's also related to the concept of
referential transparency okay any
questions good to Warren
no guys are good all right pull your
phones we're gonna do a quick challenge
with I hope you guys had a paid
attention so you have to go to the east
side that is got IT knowledge in here
too
and once you're in the site you should
thank you not to enter his pain
right so I did my
forty-five
ready Freddy
all right 66
there you go alright so the questions I
think they're gonna appear right here
and I think we can get started there is
one question at the beginning for you
guys to familiarize with this side that
it's not really intuitive so what's the
result of two plus two of course for yes
we'll have to hit the triangle the
pyramid in your phones
all right it's gonna give you ten
seconds per question there you go
good nobody know somebody as you guys
don't like a florist okay next question
who was the creator of Lisp
Oh some people worth weren't really
looking at the slice alright
FB functional programming was inspired
by quick hit the green button I
completely made that one up what are the
advantages of immutable code alright
actually some of these questions are
gonna have two possible answers so both
these are good
it's whatever resembles first so then is
Ronnie who's then good Dan you were
followed closely by someone I didn't see
who we just evolving Python types are
immutable and two possible answers
all right lists who's mutating lists who
thinks it lists are immutable you're
gonna have a bad time all right John Oh
Dan sorry
we have six down so network
John Allen Don Sonny
Alan Alan where's darling yeah a guy
from the book I have your books
yeah you have up for course for free to
have to play this thing okay which one
of the following are considered side
effects forty modules are pretty much
done which of this are the
characteristics of pure functions pure
functions whoa blue all right oh you
stopped me Mike okay we're gonna give
five of course for the first five and
he's gonna get one the characteristic of
functions first class objects this is a
final one almost done dude Sam we was
trying to test him with pie pests are we
done John no tomorrow which are the
following core function programming
functions can be replicated with list
comprehensions fall and reviews can't
sadly
there's a tiny tiny difference between
fall and reduce its actual in these
lights but I was on a hurry we didn't
cover it and finally what's the
difference between a less comprehension
and generating comprehension we didn't
cover this so sorry about that it's also
in the slides we should do not count
this one
during the comprehensions are lazy
that's the idea
actually we can say an example later
alright so Henry who's Henry
yeah we have one two three let me get do
we get the first six people stay can mhm
boohoo's boom alright big applause
perfect
[Applause]